بدوره قال رئيس الاداره الاقليميه في ديني
بروب بتروفسكا للقوات الروسيه قصفت ليلا
المنطقه بالمدفعيه الثقيله ومنظومات جراد
باكثر من 50 قذيفه
ادى الى دمار في المباني السكنيه دون ان
يسفر عن اصابات او ضحايا
قال الانفصاليون المواليون لروسيا في
دونيس ان قواتهم تواصل تقدما في محور مطار
دوناتس الدولي وعلى وشك السيطره على بلده
شمال غرب المدينه
اقتحام من البلده التي كانت تشكل خط دفاعا
متقدمه للقوات الاخرانيه شمال الدونيسك
وكانت قوته الانفصاليين اعلنت يوم الجمعه
سيطرتها على بلده في محور مطار المدينه
وبدات
احدى بلدتي ما يعرف بالطوق قرب مدينه
هذا ونشر عمده تجار الافكار الموالي
لروسيا عبر قناته على التليجرام صور لاثار
المدماري في مدينه
الشرقيه البلاد وذلك عقبه عرضها لقصف
الاوكرانيين اليوم
في المنازل والشوارع ومؤسسات خدميه في
المدينه